but if it's like nonstick but most
people hear the term entry-level model
they think of a small car with little
horsepower and low spec says cart
estimate is kirat but he says that's not
always the case after all every vehicle
manufacturer offers entry-level models
British sports car maker McLaren have
one called the 540 see it might be
pretty compact when it's got plenty of
though he finds actually entering the
car a little tricky
and while most people might find the
160,000 euro price tag a bit hefty the
car itself is anything but thanks to its
lightweight construction it weighs in at
around 1.3 tonnes
see [ __ ] you like so what's entry-level
about this car Mota zests the engine
isn't quite as powerful as the next
model up its the 540 C not the 570s and
the equipment line isn't as refined the
driver's seat is moved back and forward
manually though you can still adjust its
height electronically another weight
saving feature the lightweight chassis
means the two engines don't seem to
differ so much in day-to-day use and the
540 C does deliver the 540 horsepower
that it promises
that's 397 kilowatts and metric terms
and hence as powerful as the Porsche 911
Turbo which costs 14,000 euros more
McLaren also relies on turbo drive to
give the 3.8 liter v8 engine a boost it
can sell rate from zero to 100 at 3.5
seconds and reach top speeds of 320
kilometers an hour though the 540 C's
front axle already starts getting a bit
jittery once it hits 200 kilometres an
hour
oh yeah Montes can't wait to take a peek
under the hood there's a little button
here to lift it up but Montes is a
little bit disappointed by what he finds
apart from checking oil and water levels
you can't do anything yourself stunned
on cooking Duffman here on shine and
a poor engine is left to its own devices
behind a screen better keep it busy but
some restraint is called for if you buy
a car like this otherwise you're likely
to collect dozens of speeding tickets
and spend a fortune on gas fuel
consumption is rated at ten point seven
liters per 100 kilometers what it uses
in reality doesn't bear thinking about
Montes is really enjoying driving the
car in the open road
he says there's hardly any over or under
steering to speak of the 540 C belongs
to McLaren sport series but despite
their name these cars are designed
chiefly for road usage but of course
they're also fit for the racetrack down
here in the center console there are two
knobs to adjust the handling and
powertrain modes they have to be
activated first now the handling sent to
track but you can also switch it to
sport or normal the other performance
mode dial offers exactly the same
options he finds that these choices
really do make a difference and is
pleased that these two functions are so
easy to use independently from the
outside the 540 C doesn't resemble an
entry-level model in the slightest
instead it practically screams high-end
sports car the car is also very cleverly
streamlined so there's no need for a big
rear spoiler
all the features in the McLaren's
interior were specially manufactured by
the British car maker
Malthus would prefer the bucket seats to
be a bit narrower he's not bothered that
you have to adjust the manually but he
would like a tighter fit
he's quite slim and when he drives
around a curve he slips to the right or
the left the McLaren is upscale enough
to appeal to Porsche 911 and Audi r8
customers
my father Montes is conclusion the
McLaren 540 see closely matches the next
model up in the series and everyday
driving a bit more or less performance
doesn't really make much difference if
he wanted a McLaren he says he'd be
quite happy with the 540 C McLaren aims
to sell 4,000 cars from the sport series
by 2017 but for most people this
entry-level model will remain a dream
what connects big car shows like this
one in Paris with Mexico almost all the
car makers here have a factory in Mexico
car production has been contributing to
the Mexican economy for over 50 years
cars are mostly made for the North
American market but for other parts of
the world - howdy recently started
producing the new version of the q5 and
San Jose Chiappa
on a 200 hectare area of land the German
carmaker has built its most
state-of-the-art factory yet with its
own pressing plant body shop paint shop
and assembly plant via for Rupert
Stadler explains he was there a few
years ago when the foundation was laid
in the middle of nowhere he says where
there was nothing and now there's a new
factory I know is vac the factory was
built in record time at an altitude of
2,400 meters in the middle of the rocky
desert at a cost of over a billion euros
but vital says two years were needed
between laying the foundation stone and
beginning pre-production this was only
possible because the whole factory had
been planned and operations launched
virtually a first-in car making history
he believes then that was put into
practice in the real world so into
thought August the entire chain of
operations was enhanced - the simulation
of systems and processes it took a third
less time than usual to get the factory
up and running
howdy place particulars on the
environment the paint shop is one of the
greenest in the world very
energy-efficient with filters to reduce
emissions from the organic solvents to
almost zero
the factory has already created 4200 new
jobs in a region where unemployment is
high the company has received more than
240,000 applications many of them aren't
qualified but howdy is offering to train
them from scratch or retrain them as
Lopez says that Howdy's going to have a
very big impact in the region because
it's opened a door many people here are
not well educated or are over 40 and
don't have the right qualifications
they've been given a chance to join the
company before a lot of them were
unemployed or scared of losing their
jobs because they weren't suitably
qualified but just for my party
reality those who were qualified were
given the chance to hone their skills we
were given a six-week course in a
training center we can develop
continuously we can further our
knowledge and skills and various
seminars they don't expect us in an area
howdy is also training up young locals
at the start of their career to keep up
its standards the carmaker has exported
the much-praised German dual training
system for apprentices the combination
of theory and practice
there are currently 330 participants in
outies traineeship program
the osmium Dawid in some Eduardo
Palacios arena from Audi Mexico says the
traineeship last three years it entails
30% theory 70% practice half of it takes
place at the factory in our learning
stations at the end the trainees get a
recognized German Chamber of Commerce
certificate and one that is recognized
all over Mexico so he explains a trainee
here in Mexico has the same
qualification as a training in English
Germany are two V's in but out Iike not
build over 150,000 cars per year alone
that's why it has opened a 26 hectare
Justin sequence supplier park next to
its plant in San Jose Chiappa one of the
suppliers that has already launched
operations there is Tuson crook
automotive it supplies the front and
rear axles for the new q5 howdy has
chosen to work with about 180 suppliers
for its high-end SUV two-thirds fall
under the North American Free Trade
Agreement which means there are lower
customs duties Mexico has free trade
agreements with over 50 countries this
fact and that of low wages makes Mexico
a very attractive production center for
Audi and other car makers and their
suppliers
at a global level Mexico ranked as
seventh biggest producer of vehicles in
2015 it expects to be ranked among the
top three by 2020
Marcedes continues its off-road
offensive with the e-class
all terrain the new station wagon
features a rugged radiator grille plenty
of plastic cladding and extra large
wheels it's also been jacked up for more
ground clearance and Mercedes 4matic
all-wheel drive system comes as standard
the e-class all-terrain is due to roll
into showrooms next spring French
automaker Puzo has introduced its
all-new 5008 SUV on the outside the
family vehicle features a long hood a
sleek front grille and a sporty side
profile but it's the Seven Cedars
interior that's most impressive boasting
loads of space and flexible seating
arrangements both of the third row seats
can be folded down and easily removed as
part of its centennial celebrations BMW
is presenting the vision next 100
concept motorcycle its design sights
elements from BMWs motorettes
illustrious past but it's technology is
futuristic a new stabilization system
ensures that the bike won't topple while
standing or in motion as well as
ensuring a safer ride the bike produces
zero emissions to
Suzuki's sx/4 s-cross has had a facelift
in hungary new colors and some new
aesthetic details have transformed it
into a vehicle made for the streets of
europe that suits the preferences of
european customers our corn Chester
Sasha Kanab says that Suzuki is better
known in Germany for its runabouts but
the company wants to prove they can also
make bigger vehicles the new SX 4s cross
is very different under the hood it's
got new engines he's testing the 1.4
liter booster jet engine today it's the
more powerful of the models two new
gasoline engines Suzuki also offers a
1.6 liter diesel engine for this model
but our test car has a four-wheel drive
and a 6-speed manual transmission it can
go from 0 to 100 km/h and 10.2 seconds
and reach a maximum speed of 200
kilometers an hour fuel consumption is
quoted at 5.6 liters per 100 kilometers
the front has much more of an SUV look
than before the new grille with its
vertical slats is an eye catcher the LED
headlights are also new there's one
centimeter more ground clearance 18
centimeters in total giving the car
off-road capability with its four
different modes the all grip four-wheel
drive system also makes sense for
off-road driving and normal driving
conditions front wheel drive is used to
save on fuel the changes to the rear are
less important than those to the front
only the lights are new nothing has
changed in terms of trunk space which is
usually 430 liters but can be expanded
to 875 that's pretty average Secession
it three equipment lines are available
for the SX 4s cross we're testing the
top version which comes with a standard
sat-nav leather upholstery parking
sensors and a panoramic sunroof Suzuki
has made no compromises in terms of
safety either the standard specification
version comes with seven airbags he'll
hold control ESP ABS and cruise control
Sasha says a good car tester should
always get in the back - and he's
surprised how much space he has for his
knees he's impressed by the concave
front seat back to something that's
become very common now and it's a good
thing but he wishes he had more Headroom
so let's recap on the details one last
time the new 1.4 liter booster jet
engine isn't really a new engine sascha
notes because it was already used in the
Vitara here it puts out 103 kilowatts of
power and 220 Newton meters of torque
though nobody should worry about being
too slow in traffic facelifts often turn
out to be less dramatic than expected
and that's definitely the case here
however the expanded range of engines
might tempt new buyers but it's really
the price that's tempting the least
expensive version has a 1.0 litre
booster jet engine and produces just 82
kilowatts of power but is a snip at
under 20,000 euros in Germany
when leaves are turning and starting to
fall and many motorcyclists here in
Germany are wistfully beginning to
mothball their bikes for winter the
industry is already wetting their
appetites for next season the inter Mont
trade show in Cologne is a real
highlight for motor bike and scooter
fans the need for mobility freedom and
adventure is as strong as ever in recent
years the industry has been making
record profits and experiencing
double-digit growth from the Cologne
trade fair organization says that sales
have risen more than 10 percent over the
past few years
motorbikes and scooters are back in he
says among the younger generation - some
of the top brand models here are making
their world debut like the latest 1600
GT BMWs most powerful bike it's very
comfortable and ideal for touring
alongside performance safety features
are becoming increasingly important BMW
has now integrated its intelligent
emergency call feature for cars indoors
motorcycles
carl victor Schaller from BMW Motorrad
explains that in the event of a heart
impact and build acceleration sensors
automatically trigger an emergency call
to a BMW call center the staff can speak
directly with the driver by a microphone
and loudspeaker if there's no response
the emergency services are immediately
alerted while roaring engines can be
heard in many stands more and more
people are taking the quiet route
electric motorcycles are booming go vex
is even resurrecting the East German
Simpson Schwalbe scooter thirty years
after it went out of production thomas
google says his electric mobility
company has noticed growing acceptance
for electric vehicles especially for two
wheelers because they're increasingly
convenient you can charge them up
anywhere and so there are no
disadvantages compared to conventional
scooters and whether they're the loud or
more the silent type bikers share a
passion for a certain kind of lifestyle
and the ability to live it and
increasingly individual ways no wonder
the customized bike scene is growing big
brands also have their own stands
devoted to this trend there's something
for everyone
Ubbe anger says the appeal of
customisation lies and individualization
everybody wants things personalized he
says that the lifestyle effect has
changed the way customizing is viewed
it's not just for getting around anymore
it's a luxury item for many
motorcyclists it is actually a way of
life this season and next
many people want to own the dream
machine of their youth Dan Yoder tlemen
has actually fulfilled that dream nine
years ago he bought a BMW 730 a first
generation BMW 7-series model
he spent around 250 hours restoring the
car until it looked just the way it does
today Daniel says this BMW was a niche
model made for just two years after
seven series production began then BMW
made the switch from carburetor
technology to fuel injection that makes
this car one of the rarest seven series
models the Motor Transport Authority
estimates there are just 50 left in
Germany BMW officially introduced its 7
Series in May of 1977 the 6-cylinder
luxury sedan rounded out the automaker's
product range
Danielle's vehicle was made in 1978
making it an early first generation
model the first models came with a
choice of three engines his was fitted
with a middle-of-the-road BMW engine one
of the last to use a Solex four-barrel
carburetor
Daniel's pride and joy is his car
he's whatever he says there are two
reasons for that
first popular German TV detective Derek
drove this BMW 7-series model in the
show and this fascinated him in his
youth secondly the manager of the bank
where his father worked also drove this
exact model Daniel lived over the bank
and had access to the underground
parking garage when he was seven or
eight he couldn't understand why his dad
didn't drive a car like this but then
his father wasn't the head of a bank
that's how he came to love this model
and in 2007 for his 30th birthday he
decided to treat himself to his first
classy car decide - over time our
thoughts and rises in the boats our
cameras is done the zest i t'ought open
it may be old but this BMW still has
plenty of power under the hood it's
straight six-cylinder engine has an
output of 135 kilowatts that enables the
car to reach a top speed of 200
kilometers an hour even in its heyday
the BMW 730 was a luxury model with a
price tag of over 40,000 Deutsche marks
only top earners could afford one for
many the metallic amazonite green paint
takes a bit of getting used to but for
Daniel it had to be this color
aside from the fact that greens his
favorite color he says his parents had a
sofa in their living room in the 1980s
that was almost exactly this shade of
fern green so you could say it was love
at first sight
the color combination of green exterior
and green interior is unique from
today's standpoint but in the 70s these
colors were invoked though by the late
1970s they were out again he figures
this color combo really is one of a kind
I'm honest these days Daniel Durham on
only drives his BMW 730 for fun a
longtime member of their line EFT
antique car club he takes part and day
trips and weekend excursions then his
green car always turns heads although
many people buy classic cars as an
investment for Daniel it's never been
about the money
he feels his car itself is a treasure on
the classic car market 7 Series models
lacked the status of ones like the
Mercedes s-class these cars are bought
by people who love them they'll retain
their value if well cared for but won't
shoot up in price like vintage cars have
of late but for him that's immaterial
it's all about this car and it's
priceless
compared to other classic cars demand
for first generation BMW 7-series models
is relatively low so prices remain
moderate but no matter what its market
value Daniel wouldn't trade in his green
BMW for anything